[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi, everybody.
Did you know there's a great
new YouTube channel for machine
learning and AI developers?
It's all about TensorFlow,
and on it, we've
got lots of great
new shows for you.
For example, one of the shows
is called "TensorFlow Meets."
And on this show, I
will go out and meet
with members of the
community to talk
about what it is that you
do with TensorFlow, so we
can learn from each other.
We'll also have
"Coding TensorFlow."
And on "Coding TensorFlow,"
we'll go on a journey together,
writing the code that you will
use to build machine learning
models.
You can get it on
GitHub at this link.
There's "Ask TensorFlow,"
and on "Ask TensorFlow,"
if you ask your questions in
social media with the hashtag
#AskTensorFlow, we'll
have some of our experts
answer them in a video with you.
We'll also be covering
things such as the TensorFlow
Developer Summit, as well as
lots of more content and maybe
just a few surprises as well.
So go hit that subscribe
button, and I'll see you there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]